ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد قالت صحيفه
البريطانيه في افتتاحيتها ان على الحكومه
اعاده النظر في الخروج من الاتحاد
الاوروبي بريكسيت مشيره الى ان الاتحاد او
الاتجاه العام في البلاد يميل لاصلاح
الانفصال لتجنب كارثه الاقتصاديه جديده
وقالت صحيفه ان الزياده الضرائب والضغط
على القطعه العامه سيظهر بالدوله في
الاشهر القليله المقبله كما ستتقلص حزمه
دعم اسعار الطاقه بعد ربيع المقبل فضلا عن
خطتي بنك انجلترازيليزيادات حاده في
معادلات الفائده ستثقل تكاليف رهن
الاعقاري والاعمال وبشكل غير مباشر
واشارت الى ان ذلك يعد تحولا ملحوظه في
مثل هذا الوقت القصير مضحتنا انه منذ اقل
من شهرين عرضه وزير الماليه السابق
ميزانيه مصغره تتضمن تخفيضات ضريبيه وحزنه
لدعم الطاقه ب 72 مليار جنيه استرليني
وغياب تخفيضات هنا في الانفاق العام
العامه
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من لندن احمد
ياسين عضو حزب المحافظ البريطاني من لندن
كذلك احمد مصطفى كاتب صحفي مختص في شؤون
الدوليه اهلا
بكمين واسمحالي ان ابدا معك استاذ احمد
مصطفى همم هل هذه الدعوات او هذه الافكار
او هذه الاطروحات بمحاوله العوده
للاتحاد الاوروبي تعتقدها وارده يمكن ان
تكون واقعيه
ليست واقعيه لا يمكن القول بعوده للاتحاد
الاوروبي الانفصال حدثت تم كان هناك
استفتاء 2016 صوت في نصف البريطانيه لصالح
الخروج من اوروبا
تم الاتفاق على الخروج في حكومه بورجونسون
قبل عامين كل هذا حدث الحديث الان هو عن
طريقه الخروج الطريقه التي تمت بها الخروج
اضر بالاقتصاد البريطاني بشده
لم يكن ذلك ما يصرح به المتحمسون لبريست
من مجموعه برج الجونسون وجاكو رئيس غيرهم
لكن همم يعني حسن يشعر بريطانيا الان طبعا
ليس فقط الندم ولكن بخدعه ماء في ان
الخروج من الاتحاد الاوروبي سيكون بمثابه
انفراج اقتصاديه هائله لبريطانيا النتيجه
بريطانيا الان هي اسوا اغتصاب ليس فقط في
مجموعه السابعه ولكن حتى في مجموعه ال20
من كل الاقتصارات الاوروبيه ما رايك يا
سيد ياسين هل الخروج من الاتحاد الاوروبي
كان همم غلطه بريطانيا وهي تتحمل مسئوليته
وتتحمل تداعياته حتى هذه اللحظه والعوده
قد تكون وارده كما يقول البعض
لم تكن غلطه والبركزيت يصب في مصلحه
بريطانيا بشكل كبير وبشكل واضح ولكن ما
شاهدناه منذ اتفاقيه البركزه التي وقعها
جونسون ان الرجل الذي وقع الاتفاقيه ارتكب
اخطاء يعني تافهه وبسببها خرج من دون
ستريت ولم يستكمل المهمه يعني هو الرجل
المناسب لاستكمال هذه المهمه ولكن مع كل
الاساس هذه الاخطاء التافهه التي اوقع
نفسه فيها يعني ذهبت به خارج
والمهمه لم تستكمل بعد همم كذلك ايضا
التحديات غير المتوقع التي واجهت بريطانيا
في مقدمتها تداعيات همم انتشار فايروس
كورونا واجراءات الاغلاق اعطيت الاولويه
عن الاهتمام بملف البركزيت والاستفاده من
بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي كان هناك
جهود اوليه قامت بها الاسترس عندما كانت
وزيره العلاقات الخارجيه في حكومه باري
جونسون هي حينها وقعت حوالي 66 اتفاقيه
للتجاره الحره بين بريطانيا وتكتلات
اقتصاديه اساسيه حول العالم مثل هذه
التكتلات عجز الاتحاد الاوروبي عن يوقع
اتفاقيات لاتجار الحره معها وهنا اعطيك
فقط مثال مجلس التعاون الخليجي استمر
الاتحاد الاوروبي بالتفاوض مع مجلس
التعاون الخليجي لفتره زمنيه قاربت
العشرين عاما وانتهت تلك المفاوضات من دون
اي نتيجه والسبب واضحه وان الاتحاد
الاوروبي كتكتل اذا صح هذا التعبير هو يجب
ان يتوافق بين دوليه اولا على صيغه
تفاهميه مشتركه بين الدول اعضاء تحت ظله
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومثل هذه الصيغه
التفاهميه المشتركه يعني صعبه للغايه هناك
العديد من الامثله اصدق مثالا اقرب مثال
لذلك اتفاقيه التجاره الحره مع مع كندا
استمرت بالتفاوض حوالي سبع سنوات وكاد في
اليوم الذي كان في اليوم الذي تم التوقيع
الاتفاقيه فيه كاد برلمان اقليمي في
بلجيكا ان يودي بالاتفاقيه
وسنواتها سبع من المفاوضات
اتفضلوا استاذ مصطفى
الاوروبي ستتخلص من كثير من القيود
الاوروبيه صحيحه هناك ما يسمى
التجاره لكن ما حدث ان بريطانيا لم تستفيد
انا يعني ليس هذا كلامي ساذكر فقط ما بدا
يتحدث عنه وزراء سابقون حتى في حكومه
الاستراس همم
كورر الذي تحدث بوضوح
الكارثه التي احدثتها ليستراس اثناء
المفاوضات مع الاستراليين ايضا وزير
البيئه السابق جورج يستايس الذي تحدث عن
همم ان الاتفاقيه مع استراليا التي روا
لها همم مجموعه برج جونسون وجيكو بريسمون
على ان انجاز غير عادي ما كان ليحدث لو لم
تخرج اوروبا من الى ولم تخرج بريطانيا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي ليست جيده على الاطلاق
كل هذه الاتفاقيات التي حدثت بعد البريزات
لم تخفف بريطانيا بالعكس بريطانيا تتعرض
لخسائر نتيجه خسارتها
لقدر كبير من التجاره مع الشريك الرئيسي
لها
مصطفى ياسين يطرح نقطه اخرى يقول بانه هذا
التراجع على الاقتصادي او حتى تراجع سعر
الجنيه الاسترليني وهذه المشاكل التي
ستطال قريبا حتى الايجارات سترتفع البعض
هيرتفعت والبعض حتى ينتظر ان ترتفع اكثر
يقول بانه همم لا يتحملها الخروج من
البريكزات او لا يتحملها هذا الملف ما
يتحملها خروج شخص كان مكلف بتطبيق خطه
ويراه الانف لتطبيق هذه الخطه وهو باريس
جونس يقول بانه لملفات يعتبرها هو تافهه
هامشيه ملفات كنا تحدث معانا خرج ولم يطبق
الخطه
اليه وزير الخزانه جيرمن الذي
عفوا المشاكل في بريطانيا بدات والازمه
الاقتصاديه بدات حتى من قبل الكرونه كان
المفترض يعني لا يمكن انكار ايضا ان اتفاق
بركزي تم في ظل همم ازمه وباءنا وتم
بطريقه همم باستثناء موقف برج الجونسون
وديفيد فرس لا يوافق اغلب حزب المحافظين
على الطريقه التي تم بها يعني هذا ليس
كلامي ولكن هذا ما يقوله الان اعضاء جسر
في حزب المحافظين خارج مجموعه المجموعه
الاوروبيه للابحاث التي يقودها جاكبر
يعني هناك اسباب واقعيه
ويعني تفسر خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي اا عندما اقدم الاتحاد الاوروبي
على التمدد شرقا وضم دول مثل بلغاريا
ورومانيا التي تمثل يعني عبء على الاتحاد
الاوروبي هنا ظهرت ظهرت مشاكل عديده في
مقدمتها ملف الهجره وكيف يمكن لهيتين
الدولهتين ان تنضمان الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهما يعني اقتصاديا غير يعني متكافئان مع
باقي الدول الاوروبيه كذلك ايضا يجب ان
نذكر بتطور جد هام بعد ازمه الديون
الاوروبيه في عام 2012 جاء التوجه
الاوروبي للمزيد من المركزيه ضمن منطقه
اليورو اي ان كل اولويه الاتحاد الاوروبي
قال تكتل اقتصادي اذا صعد تعبير كان ينصب
بشكل اساسي ضمن منطقه اليورو هذا يتعارض
مع الدول التي هي عضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي
خارج منطقه اليورو مثل بريطانيا لذلك كان
من ال- من الواجب ومن اللازم ان تخرج
بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي تحت وطء
الاعباء الكبيره لملف الهجره وكيف ان
البلغار والرومانيين بداوا يتجولون في
الدول الاوروبيه همم يعني همم يقتدون على
نظام الرعايه الاجتماعيه ومن دون ان تقدم
بلغاري ورومانيا اي فوائد الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومثل هذا
المد او التوسع شرقا جاء تحت الهيم من
الامريكيه لذلك ردود الفعل البريطانيين
للخروج من الاتحاد الاوروبي جاءت واقعيه
وبالتاكيد تصيد في مصلحه بريطانيا
لحزب المحافظين وخاصه المجموعه المتحمسه
يعني كان هذا هو الشعار الاساسي الذي ادى
ان يكون الاستفتاء بازيد كثيرا من نسبه
بريطانيا هو مساله الهجره لكن انا ساذكر
فقط ما قاله رئيس الاتحاد الصناعات
البريطانيه اليوم من ان بريطانيا بحاجه
الى الهجره هناك مشكله حقيقيه حدثت في
بريطانيا بعد بريجزت تساهمت في هذا الترتي
الاقتصادي وهي مثلا هناك السوق العمل
مضغوط جدا ليس بسبب البطاله ولا بسبب
الرغبه في التوظيف او عدم قدره الاقتصاد
على توظيف ولكن بسبب عدم وجود العماله همم
اذكر مثال بسيط لضيفك الكريم العام الماضي
الى حدثت ازمه محطات البنزين احتجت
بريطانيا الى الالاف من سائق الشاحنات ان
ياتوا من اوروبا واضطرت الى تعديل همم
قواعد واجراءات التاشيرات الدخول حتى تاتي
بالالاف من السائقين لحل ازمه
الشاحنات وازمه الوقود في محطات البنزين
ماذا حدث لم ياتي يعني لم يتقدم بطلب الى
بريطانيا الا بضع 10 لم تتمكن من ذلك هذه
واحده في اسكتلندا الان يعاني المزارعون
الاسكتلنديون بشده من نقص العماله
الموسميه وهذا واحد من الاسباب التي يمكن
ان تسهم في ان يصوت الاسكتلنديون في اي
استفتاء قادم لصالح الانفصال على المملكه
المتحده المساله ببساطه ان كثيرا مما ذكر
حتى الحديث عن التوسعاد الاوروبي شرقا وان
هؤلاء المهاجرون يستغلون ال- ال- ال-
النظام الاجتماعي والصحيح بريطانيا يعني
همم لا يمكن على اطلاق المملكه من 2016
الفريا الاساسيه التي كانت شعار هذه
المجموعه في حزب المحافظين من ان اوروبا
تاخذ 360 مليون جنيه استرلينيه اسبوعيا من
نظام همم الرعايه الصحيه البريطاني وحكمت
المحكمه قبل فتره بان هذه كربه
طيب استاذ ياسين بكل ما ذكره ضيفي من
ربما مشاكل اندلعت بعد بريكزيت بعد خروج
بريطاني من الاتحاد الاوروبي حضرتك تختلف
معه واضح نقاط الاختلاف بحسب الملفات طبعا
ولكن اليوم هناك اصوات تتحدث عن عوده او
عن شكل من اشكال التوافق الجديد مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان لن يكون عوده كامله
كيف سيكون هذا توافق لان البعض يتحدث عن
البدء حتى في حكومه بريطانيا بالتواصل مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي من اجل همم ابرام
اتفاقيات تضعها دائما في همم
اطار همم انتفاع من بعض الاستثمارات وبعض
ال- اا تبادلات التجاريه هل هذا يمكن
قبل الاجابه لسؤالك ضعيف فقط اوضح نقطه
بخصوص ملف
المهاجرين لان هناك فرق كبير جدا بين من
ياتي مهاجرا الى بريطانيا
ومباشره يعتمد على النظام الرعايه
الاجتماعيه وبين المهاجر الكفر وهنا ما
اقدم او ما ما اعتمده برج جونسون في
حكومته لتطبيق نظام بوين سيستم نظام
النقاط اي ان ان الهجره القادمه الى
بريطانيا يجب ان تتوافق وتنسجم مع حاجه
الاقتصاد من وظائف شاغره وهذا بالضبط
بالضبط
في تطبيقه ولكن كانت الاولويه في حكم
للتعامل مع تداعيات انتشار فارسكور
بالنسبه همم
جونس بدا قبل ذلك وكان هناك تحضير يعني
المفروض انا بريطانيا منذ تقدمت بملف خروج
من الاتحاد الاوروبي اكيد بانه كانت هناك
خطط نتحدث عن سنوات لا نتحدث عن سنه او
اثنتين
منذ توقيع اتفاقيه البريزات يعني بعد
حوالي شهر واجهت بريطانيا تداعيات انتشار
فيروس كورونا وبالتاكيد اعطيه الاولويه
المطلقه للتعامل مع التداعيات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه لانتشار فيروس كورونا ومثل
هذا الوضع استمر لحوالي السنتين همم بعد
بعد انتشار فارس كورونا يعني بني العالم
بتداعيات الازمه الاوكرانيات لذلك يمكن
القول واقعيا بان الى الان بريطانيا لم
تعطى الفرصه الكامله للاستفاده من خروجها
من الاتحاد بالنسبه
للبريطانيا الاستاذ مصطفى احمد كاتب صحفيه
مختص في شؤون الدوليه شكرا لكم
السلام عليكم